>> Tucker: IT'S BEEN TWO
WEEKS SINCE ROBERT MUELLER
FINISHED HIS INVESTIGATION
AND FOUND WHAT FEW
SUSPECTED, SOME OF US
EXPECTED PRETTY VEHEMENTLY
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND THE GOVERNMENT OF
RUSSIA.
TO THAT EXTENT THE CASE IS
CLOSED.
MEMBERS OF MUELLER'S TEAM
WANT TO CONTINUE THE
ALLEGATIONS IN A SERIES OF
LEAKS TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" THEY HAVE COMPLAINED
THAT THE REPORT, DESPITE
FINDING NO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY, SHOULD BE RELEASED
BECAUSE IT IS, QUOTE,
DAMAGING TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN OTHER WORDS, PROSECUTORS
WORKING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NO LONGER SEE
THEIR JOB AS ENFORCING THE
JOB INSTEAD THE POINT IS A
POLITICAL VENDETTA IN AN
ATTEMPT TO INFLUENCE
NARRATIVES ABOUT PEOPLE THEY
DISLIKE.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
IS THAT A PROPER ROLE OF A
PROSECUTOR WORKING FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GLENN
GREENWALD CO-FOUNDED THE
INTERCEPT AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
MOST RECENT "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY ABOUT WHAT APPARENTLY
IS IN THE REPORT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN?
>> WELL, IT'S SIMILAR TO THE
JOURNALISM THAT HAS FUELED
THE THREE YEAR HOAX THAT HAS
DROWNED U.S. DISCOURSE
NAMELY THAT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," "THE WASHINGTON
POST" GIVES ANONYMITY TO
TOTALLY UNKNOWN PEOPLE TO
MAKE CLAIMS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY OF ANY SPECIFICS
UNACCOMPANIED BY ANY
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
SO THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ANALYZE AND JOURNALISTS SEE
IT AND START CELEBRATING
ONLINE ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
CABLE NEWS AS THOUGH IT'S
SOME SORT OF A SMOKING GUN.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE
PERSONALLY ANY PROBLEM WITH
HAVING THE MUELLER REPORT
PUBLISHED SINCE I DON'T
THINK THAT IN THIS CASE, A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS JUST
ACTING AS A PROSECUTOR, THEY
ARE ALSO THERE TO SAY WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL BENEFIT
FROM THAT SO THAT WE NO
LONGER HAVE TO HAVE CIA
LEAKS TRYING TO MANIPULATE
OUR BRAIN.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> ONE THING WE DO KNOW,
TUCKER ABOUT THIS REPORT.
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE.
ONE THING WE DO KNOW THAT
THESE COMPLAINTS FROM THESE
ANONYMOUS LEAKERS WHOEVER
THEY ARE ANONYMOUS OBJECTORS
NOT COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
SECTION OF BARR'S LETTER
THAT REPORTED THAT MUELLER
FOUND NO COLLUSION.
THEY ARE ONLY COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE PART WHERE MUELLER
SAID IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WHETHER
TRUMP OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
SO, IT'S AMAZING THAT
ACTUALLY THE PART ABOUT THE
KNOW COLLUSION GOT BOLSTERED
BECAUSE EVEN THESE
MALCONTENTS COMPLAINING TO
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
NOMINATION MUSTILY ARE
ANONYMOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE
THE PROBLEM WITH THE PORTION
NO COLLUSION WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE OBSTRUCTION
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE
PEOPLE DISMISSED YOU ARE ONE
OF THEM AS AGENTS OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
WHERE IS THE JUSTICE FOR
THEM?
WHERE DO THEY GET THEIR
REPUTATIONS BACK?
>> I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS IS
THAT JOURNALISM MORE THAN
EVER IS A PROFESSION OF
COMPLETE GROUP THINK AND MOB
RULE IN PART BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO BE A
JOURNALIST THESE DAYS
BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS.
BIG MEDIA OUTLETS ARE LAYING
OFF HUGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE A YOUNG
JOURNALIST THE LAST THING
YOU WANT TO DO IS STICK YOUR
HEAD UP AND CHALLENGE THE
PREVAILING CONSENSUS BECAUSE
YOU COULD LOSE YOUR JOB OR
IF YOU WOULD LOSE YOUR JOB
IT WOULD BE HARD TO GET
ANOTHER JOB.
AND ALSO TWITTER MAKES IT SO
THAT JOURNALISTS CONSTANTLY
TALK TO ONE ANOTHER AND
CREATE THESE SORT OF GANGS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO PUNISH
ANYBODY WHO CHALLENGES THEIR
ORTHODOXIES.
AND I THINK JOURNALISM HAS
COMPLETELY DISGRACED ITSELF
AT THE EXACT TIME THAT THEY
ARE CLAIMING THAT A GRAVE
DANGER TO THE REPUBLIC IS
THAT TRUMP IS DEMEANING
JOURNALISTS.
THEY HAVE DONE TO DEMEAN
THEIR PROFESSION WITH THIS
BEHAVIOR CALLING PEOPLE
RUSSIAN AGENTS WHO QUESTION
THEM OR TRUMP SUPPORTERS OR
APOLOGISTS OR DENIALISTS
THEY HAVE A WHOLE LONG LINE
OF ACCUSATIONS AND NEW TERMS
TO STIGMATIZE ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THEIR DISSENT AND
IT'S REALLY EFFECTIVE FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO UNLIKE US
DON'T HAVE A ESTABLISHED
PLATFORMS AND IT'S BEEN
REALLY EFFECTIVE TO PREVENT
THEM FROM BEING QUESTIONED
OR CHALLENGED.
>> Tucker: HERE IS A
QUESTION I HAVE BEEN WANTING
TO ASK YOU FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU ARE MAKING YOUR CRITIQUE
FROM THE LEFT.
YOU ARE ON THE LEFT AND NOT
A TRUMP FAN.
THAT'S A TOUGH POSITION TO
TAKE AND HAVE YOU MAINTAINED
IT THIS WHOLE TIME.
WHY WERE YOU ABLE TO
MAINTAIN AN INDEPENDENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS WHEN SO
MANY OTHERS WEREN'T?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S AMAZING.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THE
QUESTION IS THERE EVIDENCE
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE
WAS COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS
COMPLETELY BERRETH OF
IDEOLOGY.
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER YOU
ARE ON THE LEFT OR RIGHT
TECHNOLOGICAL QUESTION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
HAPPENED IS THAT EVERYTHING
IS SO TRIBAL BLIZZED, SO
THEY ACTUALLY WANT YOU, IF
YOU ARE TO MAINTAIN YOUR
GOOD STANDING ON THE LEFT TO
LIE.
THEY WANT -- THEY ARE
DEMANDING YOU LIE.
THEY ARE DEMANDING YOU SAY
THAT YOU SEE EVIDENCE AND
YOU SEE A CONVINCING CASE
FOR A CONSPIRACY THEORY EVEN
IF YOU DON'T REALLY SEE IT.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT UNLIKE
ESTABLISHMENT JOURNALISTS
LIKE JEREMY AND MATT TLAIB
AND MYSELF THERE WERE A LOT
OF
JOURNALISTS WHO ARE VERY
VULNERABLE WHO HAVE THE
COURAGE TO INCUR THE WRATH
OF THIS PROFESSION IN ORDER
TO DO WHAT JOURNALISTS
SHOULD DO WHICH IS TO SAY
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY THINK
WITHOUT ANY FEAR WHO IT
ANGERS AND VERY FEW OF THEM
ARE WILLING TO DO THAT AND
THEY DESERVE A LOT OF CREDIT
FOR THAT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE
COMPLETELY.
WE HAVE HAD TRACY ON THIS